As more Conjuring movies are added to the
franchise, keeping track of things can get
confusing, especially since they jump around
chronologically.
Luckily, we’ve figured out when everything
takes place.
From freaky nuns to haunted houses, here's
the entire Conjuring Universe story explained.
Chronologically speaking, The Conjuring Universe
all starts with The Nun.
The film takes place in 1952, at the Abbey
of St. Carta in Romania, where Father Burke
and a novitiate, Sister Irene, are investigating
the death of one of the abbey's nuns.
They discover the nuns have been spending
most of their time praying in shifts to keep
a nun-shaped evil entity from hitchhiking
its way out into the real world on a human
host.
As it turns out, the abbey was originally
built by a duke during the Middle Ages who
was more interested in demon worship than
Catholicism.
He managed to raise the demon Valak but was
stopped by a group of Christian knights who
were able to seal Valak for a while.
With the help of a local man named Frenchie,
Father Burke and Sister Irene seem to finally
banish Valak back to Hell.
But as it happens, Valak manages to hitch
a supernatural ride out of town on Frenchie's
back.
The story of Annabelle starts in 1943 with
Annabelle: Creation, when a dollmaker named
Samuel Mullins and his wife Esther lose their
seven-year-old daughter, Annabelle, in a freak
car accident.
About 12 years later, the Mullins open their
doors to a group of orphaned girls and the
nun tasked with their care.
When one of the orphans stumbles upon a porcelain
doll in a locked bedroom, she unwittingly
releases a demon that wreaks havoc on the
house and its inhabitants.
It's soon revealed that the Mullins had been
tricked into letting a demon take possession
of one of Samuel's dolls, and it's now decided
to try and find a human host.
By the end of the ordeal, the demon has succeeded
in possessing the unlucky orphan, who escapes
and, now going by the name Annabelle, winds
up being adopted by a nice family in Santa
Monica.
There, she grows up, runs away, joins a cult,
and then returns to murder her adoptive parents.
As it turns out, the poor adopted parents
of Annabelle live next door to John and Mia
Form, the main protagonists of 2014's Annabelle.
John has given his wife Mia an antique porcelain
doll as a gift for their unborn child.
But after Annabelle and her boyfriend kill
her parents, they move on to the Form residence,
where Annabelle immediately takes a liking
to Mia's antique doll.
"I like your dolls."
When the human Annabelle dies, the demon hops
into the doll.
Terror sets in as the newly demonic doll decides
to torment the Form family.
Willing to trade her own soul to save her
newborn daughter, Mia tries to jump out of
her window with the doll.
Luckily, John and Mia's friend Evelyn arrive
in time to stop her, and Evelyn sacrifices
herself to save the family.
In the end, an unsuspecting woman buys the
doll from a toyshop as a gift for her daughter,
a nurse.
In The Conjuring, we revisit that nurse who
is now at the mercy of the demon spirit trapped
inside the toy.
So the Warrens take the doll off the nurse's
hands and move on to their next case.
In 1971, the Warrens are teaching a class
on demonology at Massachusetts Western University.
During the lecture, they play footage of a
possessed man named Maurice, who Ed explains
killed himself after attempting to shoot his
wife.
Maurice is Frenchie, the nice guy who spent
some time in Romania in the '50s and came
home with a demon nun as a souvenir.
One of the attendees at the Warrens' demonology
lecture is Carolyn Perron, whose family has
recently moved into a Rhode Island farmhouse.
Unfortunately, they're now being tormented
by a malevolent, clap-happy spirit.
After some digging, the Warrens discover the
house was built on land that once belonged
to a witch named Bathsheba.
Unfortunately, that discovery comes a little
late.
Bathsheba has already set her sights on Carolyn,
and the now-possessed mother brings her kids
back to the house to kill them.
The Warrens show up just in time, and the
curse of Bathsheba is lifted, finally leaving
the Perrons with a livable farmhouse.
When Ed and Lorraine Warren are needed on
an overnight investigation, they hire a girl
named Mary Ellen to stay over and keep an
eye on their daughter, Judy.
Unfortunately, Mary Ellen's friend Daniela
drops by the house uninvited.
She finds a way into the Warrens' artifact
room, disturbs Annabelle, and unleashes every
ghost and demon the Warrens have trapped in
their basement.
The girls spend the night essentially playing
hide and seek with a bunch of possessed objects
before Annabelle is returned to her case once
and for all.
In 1973, Anna Tate-Garcia is a social worker
who gets mixed up with La Llorona when she
takes the sons of a woman named Patricia Alvarez
to the police, unwittingly allowing the titular
spirit access to kill them.
As a result, Anna's own children are targeted
by the spirit, so Anna seeks help from Father
Perez, the priest from Annabelle who obviously
has some experience with evil beings.
He tells her about a former priest named Rafael
Olvera who can banish the entity.
One banished spirit later, and Anna and her
children are safe, although she keeps the
necklace that once belonged to the wailing
woman.
In a deleted scene, it's revealed that she
hands the necklace over to Rafael.
"What are you going to do with this?"
"I know a couple on the east coast who look
after things like this."
Valak makes its return in 1976 during The
Conjuring 2, the film that sees Ed and Lorraine
Warren seemingly defeat the spirit for good.
Beginning in 1976, the Warrens are investigating
the infamous Amityville murders, and Lorraine
has a vision where she comes face to face
with Valak and a vision of her husband's death.
Lorraine continues to see visions of the demon
nun, even as the pair travel to Enfield, England,
where the Hodgson family has been experiencing
paranormal activity.
When it appears as though the entire haunting
is a hoax put on by the family to gain fame,
the Warrens pack up their things to leave.
But Lorraine soon realizes that Valak has
been behind the entire thing, and they return
to the house in a last ditch effort to save
the family.
Ed almost falls to his death in the process,
leaving Lorraine to go head to head with Valak
herself.
She succeeds in banishing the demon by using
its name and pulls Ed to safety.
"You are Valak.
The Defiler.
The profane.
The marquis of snakes."
The day is saved, and everything seems to
be going smoothly...at least until the next
film in the franchise gets released.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.